Okay, let's follow up on what's going on with
the Ukraine story.
As I told you yesterday, every couple of hours
we get some additional confirmation or admission
that the entire Donald Trump extortion of
the Ukrainian president by withholding hundreds
of millions of dollars in aid under the demand
that Ukraine smear.
Joe Biden is coming out as a reported from
the beginning.
Exactly every few hours we learned.
Another 5% of the story is true.
Now.
You might remember yesterday we learned that
Donald Trump indeed withheld the aide and
in fact we found out that the decision was
made just a few days before Donald Trump's
July, 2019 phone call with the Ukrainian president,
but you might also recall that Donald Trump
explained the reason he didn't want to give
you crane the money was because he didn't
want to give money to a corrupt country like
he supposedly discussed on the phone with
the Ukrainian president.
That was explanation number one.
Donald Trump has now come up with a completely
different explanation, which I guess we can
call explanation number two which is that
the reason he withheld the aid from Ukraine
is he was mad at the European union for not
having contributed more money to Ukraine,
which is not even remotely believable.
Donald Trump spoke to reporters before heading
to meetings at the United nations in New York
city, which were an entirely separate gong
show that I will talk about with you a little
bit later on today.
And Donald Trump said, yeah, I did withhold
the financial aid from Ukraine, but it was
because he wants other countries in Europe
to be giving more money to Ukraine.
Not of course because he was trying to strong
arm Ukraine into investigating and subsequently
smearing Joe Biden.
Let's take a look at the video.
Also note that Donald Trump says in the same
sentence that he gave them the money but that
he would withhold it again, which is an implicit
confirmation that he did withhold it, which
he previously admitted to but now denies.
And then immediately self contradicts.
If my explanation is confusing, if that summary
is confusing, then uh, you are correctly understanding
it.
It is incredibly confusing.
Take a look at this.
So here's the story.
Very simply, we're watching Venezuela very
closely as far as withholding funds.
Those funds were paid, they were fully paid.
But my complaint has always been, and I'd
withhold again and I'll continue to withhold
until such time as Europe and other nations
contribute to Ukraine because they're not
doing it to see United States, we're putting
up the bulk of the money and I'm asking why
is that?
And I want Europe and it's always been this
and everybody knows it.
Every single reporter knows it.
Everybody in the administration knows that
what I want and I insist on it, is that Europe
has to put up money for Ukraine also.
Why is it only the United States putting up
the money?
So
listen, Trump's definitely panicking here,
but this is also a strategy sometimes known
as the Gish Gallop, sometimes known as the
fire hose of falsehood, and Rudy Giuliani
has been a big player in Donald Trump employing
this strategy.
You say something different every day.
Rudy is a pro at it.
Trump is pretty good at it.
You say one thing and then the next day you
say the opposite and what you're counting
on is people ultimately just being too damn
exhausted or confused to really figure it
out.
Combined with bamboozling your own supporters
into believing that you at some point explained
it.
Uh, even though they're all contradictory
explanations and unfortunately it often works,
they're actually doing something right here,
which is that while everyone who cares about
the facts is busy trying to figure out what
happened, Trump and Rudy and everybody else
are trying to get ahead of it and shaping
the narrative.
Just like the William Barr propaganda letter
was able to get out ahead of the Mueller report
and obfuscate and completely mislead with
bars, summary of Mueller's report.
Then they use that bogus propaganda letter
as the reference document that all the Trumpists
point to and say, we got the real story.
We got it in William Barr's letter.
Even though that letter was completely divorced
from the reality of what the Mueller report
said.
Now, as I mentioned to you yesterday, the
real story here is the surprise, a suppression
of the whistleblower report, and that has
gone by the wayside.
And the discussion is increasingly shaped
by Donald Trump about the reasons why he withheld
the aid and the content of that July, 2019
phone call with the Ukrainian president.
What we really need is the whistleblower complaint
and the whistleblower to testify under oath,
not some absurd phone call transcript that
Donald Trump now says he is going to put out.
And that is exactly what we want to talk about
next.
Let's dig into the transcript